[bell rings]
- DUDE.
HEY, YOU GOING TO RAY'S PARTY?
- YEAH, I'M GOING.
- YOU KNOW,
AMY'S GONNA BE THERE.
- YEAH, I KNOW.
- THINGS HAVE BEEN
REAL GOOD WITH HER, MAN.
TONIGHT COULD BE THE NIGHT.
- COULD BE.
- DUDE, ARE YOU OKAY?
- NOT REALLY, DUDE.
- WHAT'S WRONG?
YOU GET THE HOTTEST GIRL
AT A PARTY WITH NO PARENTS.
YOU'RE DEFINITELY GONNA HIT THAT
FOR SURE TONIGHT, MAN.
YOU'RE GONNA LOSE
THAT V FOR GOOD!
[slams]
- MY PENIS IS WHITE.
- EXCUSE ME?
- I HAVE A WHITE PENIS.
- WHAT?
BUT YOU'RE BLACK.
- NUH-UH. I'M BI-RACIAL.
ALL THE WHITE WENT STRAIGHT
TO MY PENIS.
- THAT--WHAT--WHAT,
YOU MEAN, LIKE, THE COLOR?
OH.
- YEAH.
- BUT WAIT, [bleep], DUDE.
I MEAN, HOW BAD COULD IT BE?
- IT'S BAD.
- HOW BAD?
- IT'S LIKE A SNICKERS.
- REGULAR OR FUN SIZE?
- WHICH ONE DO YOU GET
AT HALLOWEEN?
- FUN SIZE.
- THAT'S THE ONE.
- [bleep]
- I KNOW.
WHAT AM I GONNA DO?
I MEAN, I...
HOW AM I GONNA HIT IT WITH AMY
WITH MY LITTLE WHITE PENIS.
EVERYONE'S GONNA FIND OUT
AND I'M NEVER GONNA HEAR
THE END OF IT.
- DUDE, DUDE, DUDE.
- AMY'S WHITE.
SHE'S NOT GONNA CARE.
- REALLY?
- YEAH.
SHE'S WHITE.
- I GUESS YOU'RE RIGHT.
I MEAN, SHE'S PROBABLY NOT EVEN
GONNA KNOW THE DIFFERENCE.
- NAH, MAN.
WHITE GIRL, WHITE PENIS.
YOU'RE ALL GOOD.
[bell rings]
HEY, THERE HE IS.
HOW'D IT GO LAST NIGHT?
- DON'T WANNA TALK ABOUT IT.
- WELL, WHAT HAPPENED?
- BLACK VAGINA.